breaking Biden targets president Trump
quote Maga extremists in unhinged angry
Valley Forge speech before leaving the
stage Biden yelled out I understand
power I just I just this dude I'm sorry
man Joe Biden is just not with it okay
he he is old he is
incomprehensible and the idea that he
could hold this position is laughable
but of course there are a lot there are
a lot of people that want him to have
this position to be fair that number is
dwindling every single day we had that
story yesterday where his volunteers are
quitting in droves but let's uh let's
start by playing this clip from
cpan because you know sometimes I you I
don't know if I would use the word
unhinged as liberally as say like the
post millennial would but I have to
agree with him at least here because
when Joe Biden says we almost lost our
country over January 6 I'm like unhinged
absolutely detached from reality after
January 6 one of the first things I said
was guys it's not the 1600s anymore you
can't seize control of a government by
standing in a building but Joe Biden
apparently thinks it is because he's
probably old enough to remember but
here's the clip let's play it I just
visited the grounds of Aly Forge I've
been there a number of times since the
time I Was A Boy Scout years
ago you know it's the very site that I
think every American should visit
because it tells the story of the pain
and the suffering and the true
patriotism it took to make him
America Today We Gather in a New Year
some 246 years later just one day before
January
6 a date forever shared in our memory
because it was on that day that we
nearly lost America lost it all today
we're here to answer the most important
of questions is democracy still
America's sacred cause no it was never
I don't think
work this is not rhetorical academic or
hypothetical whether the democracy is
still America's sacred cause is the most
urgent question of our time he's correct
well he's he's correct see the the
parasitic woke individuals who are
trying to displace the American
constitutional republic with their
Multicultural democracy are terrified
that those who believe in the
constitutional republic and the vision
of the founding fathers they're they're
terrified that uh we're winning and so
when Joe Biden gets up there and says
our democracy you need to understand
he's not talking about you guys because
yeah when when we sit here and say this
country has never been a democracy he
clearly isn't talking to us during this
was really fascinating during the covid
lockdowns when you saw Ronda santis
releasing relieving the the the lockdown
pressure when you Christy know she
didn't lock down South Dakota Joe Biden
made a statement about how we are all
doing this thing how we must do this we
are doing this and I noticed something
real interesting I said that's
fascinating because the red States
aren't doing this only the blue states
are so when Joe Biden addresses the
nation and says what we are doing he's
explicitly saying I am not talking to
you Republicans and when he does this
it's the exact same message it's uh it's
actually a maist or or it hearkens back
to maoism um when Mao would talk about
the the Communists he would talk about
democracy and he would talk about uh you
know the Chinese people and stuff but he
was only talking about people that
shared his political perspective James
Lindsay has a great and I know I bring
up James Lindsay a lot but James Lindsay
has a great uh podcast on this that goes
through one of ma speeches and actually
Compares it to one of Joe Biden's
speeches and I will find it and post it
on my Twitter account but it's it's what
they do they they constantly like they
exclude intentionally with language that
sounds inclusive but essentially if you
are not thought of as or if you're not
in their in group you're thought of as
an as not a whole person that's one of
the things that M said if you weren't a
communist you didn't have a soul like
they really looked at it like almost a
spiritual thing so um it doesn't
surprise me it doesn't do anything that
he said he was going to do when it comes
to trying to bring the us together so
reminds me like when they said not my
president but like an inversion of that
like not my people yeah almost yeah I
like when I talk to children in
particular they say what former
government in he say let's say the
pledge allegiance pledge allegiance to
the flag the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
right there in the Pledge of Allegiance
and when these liberals come up and say
democracy and ignore that we're a
republic with constitutional laws and
rights it's as if they think they can
just whatever they feel like make it the
law even it totally tramples your rights
as an individual your freedoms it's not
our government I think that that's uh I
think that the the attempts to adjust
language and meanings of words is is
actually or what it boils down to is an
attempt to circumvent the law because if
they can convince you that the words
contained in a piece of legislation
don't mean what they plainly mean what
they plainly what you would plainly
understand them to mean then the whole
meaning of the Law changes that's one of
the things again that you hear you hear
uh land dedications often and those
should be completely and totally uh off
limits because what it does is it plants
the seed of illegitimacy of the United
states that means that the the land that
you're on whoever owns it they acquired
it illegitimately that means that the
government can take it because you're
not protected by the Fourth Amendment
for illegitimately acquired lands and
those kind of twisting of meanings is
what the left does constantly they've
been doing it and if people want to
argue and say no right now we are
literally in the United States arguing
over what a woman is they they they
Democrats the corporate press they're
very good at controlling the debate
itself and and pulling you away from
arguing about what you want into arguing
on their terms so instead of arguing why
we should get rid of gun gun control
we're arguing to what degree we accept
gun control and to be fair it is
Republicans in the past who have been in
favor of gun control too yes but where
we are now the people who claim that
we're a democracy are the people who
think that they can simply get together
and if there are more of them than you
they can decide to vote and you no
longer have rights that's not how a
republic Works a democracy is two wolves
and a lamb deciding what's for lunch a
republic is a well-armed lamb contesting
the vote that's I believe I'm probably
uh I'm probably not getting it
absolutely correctly but I believe
Benjamin Franklin said that that's the
point the Wolves can vote whatever they
want you have a right to live they can't
just vote to eat you yeah but the way
these people view it is look there
there's a reason why Joe Biden is it is
it is it is unambiguous he is
facilitating illegal immigration into
this country on a mass scale colluding
with human traffickers and he is him his
administration explicitly smuggling
children in the dead of night on these
planes and faster and more than ever and
it's because their their their mentality
is if you if the population of her
country doesn't agree with you import a
different one and the only way to say
democracy it's mob rule yeah if you have
51% of the vote you can take away the
rights of the other 49% and take the
thing like free speech I never thought
you know in my last four years in
Congress when Democrats had told control
that they really thought they could
throw people off the internet I mean
when they threw Donald Trump off Twitter
for example you know you think if you
could throw the president off do you
think the rest of Americans won't be
thrown off the social media if they if
the left or the owners think it's
something you just say something you
disagree with and to think that they can
tell us what we can say and what we can
even think and I'm telling you that I've
seen it man in Congress I've seen them
put that stuff in the Witch Hunt
investigations where the rule of law has
been applied one way for Republicans
another way for Democrats
it is scary and and you mentioned you
know anti-communist my mother fled a
communist country she was born and
raised in Cuba okay and she came here
when she was 20 to live in Freedom as
have many other immigrants who've come
here legally and to see the left in this
country act that way that we're not a
republic it's whatever they want they
can do to us it is scary and it is it is
as scary as your listeners might think
if not more so what I've actually seen
Michael malice makes the excellent point
it is it it it is much much it can be
much much worse than you think yeah
people don't realize what bad is yeah
and so they hear these stories about
communism and it's just
like the typical thing you hear about
what communist countries do is the light
side of how bad it gets yeah today uh
shout out to the punk rock MBA on
Twitter he is a YouTuber his name is
Finn mckeny he made a uh you a video
about uh the breakup of um Rage Against
the Machine and he was uh rightly
critical of the of the band using
communist imagery it's it's unacceptable
uh it's it's like using Nazi IM imagery
Communists killed millions and millions
and millions of people there's a reason
why I say every day that I'm that I'm on
the show that I'm an anti-communist
counterrevolutionary because that's an
actual like there are people in the
United States Congress that are in the
DSA the DSA constantly tweets supportive
messages about Marx they tweet
supportive messages about Lenin like
this is not a joke you know and you
bring it up to people the the they're so
quick to say that we have a right-wing
problem in the United States to the
point where the right is almost just the
the concept of the right is synonymous
with bad and that's just so detached
from reality you can look at the right
and say there are there are bad things
that have been done from people on the
right or bad ideas that have come from
the right fine but to to think that an
entire
philosophy because right now on the
right is where the enlightenment lives
right like all of your romantic
philosophies like like socialism is a
romantic philosophy it's based in the
idea that that you can Will things into
existence as opposed to reason you know
like the like the Enlightenment and the
idea that this stuff is acceptable it's
just it's it's so bad for the country
and it will cause massive problems and
we're starting to see him it's bad for
the world yeah 100% absolutely yeah yeah
it's failed everywhere it's been tried
mhm we need to try it again yep I mean I
I they're not going to stop trying I can
go on and on about this you see that
same here man that Meme where that uh
what was that woman she's like from Al
jaer Plus or whatever and she says you
know just because socialism has been
implemented properly doesn't mean we
just give up yeah sometimes when you you
you you got to break some eggs or
whatever and then someone responds with
oops I burn this a fle and it shows The
Killing Fields or whatever like like
dude nobody knows about all these things
that happened they only know about like
the right stuff and they don't realize
socialism is a road to Communism the
whole point I I was talking over the
holidays with people and everyone's
heard of the right-wing boogy man Joe
Biden giving the speech like and and I'm
talking to people I'm like did you know
that in 2020 we saw the worst rights
this country seen in five decades it was
the left did you know that on May 29th
2020 thousands of far-left extremists
firebombed the White House setting fire
to a guard poost setting fire to St
John's Church the historical church
across the street uh 70 plus police
officers were injured in the scuffle and
the president was is forced into an
emergency bunker they go what we've had
people on this show when Maran
Williamson I asked her and she's like I
don't know what happened with what are
you talking about it's like how do you
not know what is happening in your
backyard look Mary Williamson is a very
very nice lady and she is more deserving
of being president than Joe Biden and
any other Democrat running for the
Democrats but I got to be honest if you
don't know that the house you are
seeking to occupy was firebombed only a
couple years ago I'm not sure you're fit
for the
job it's something you should know they
call them mostly peaceful protests when
when they do it when they were burning
police station burn down police station
which which you like young people don't
realize it but I mean I'm probably your
age you're probably my age like back in
the 80s these kinds of of of phrases we
were familiar with because we would
watch show I watched a bunch of shows
about you know about Russia about a lot
of stuff about uh East Germany there was
this one show about paintball like these
kids that used to play paintball and
they got mixed up with spies in East
Germany it was super cool but the point
is like you would hear how in these in
communist countries and in socialist
countries how phrases would be said and
everybody was aware that they did not
mean what they said like the words that
they were saying and the meaning behind
the words were totally in congruous well
it's like uh it's like what we saw with
VI ramaswami gets questioned by that
Washington postom and she says you
condemn white supremacy and he's like I
condemn all forms of racial
discrimination and it's because white
supremacy to the left means something
different than what it actually means
they they they have their own different
language it's it's fascinating they use
words to that to them mean something but
to US mean something different on
purpose to trick us and to trick the
ignorant and so when vamas Swami gets
interviewed by those two by that Dasha
Burns or whatever her name is it's one
of the most dis like just yo that lady
needs to be fired but I understand BC is
not is not a news organization they're
an activist organization so why would
they fire their prosers but this woman
Dasha is not interviewing a presidential
candidate she's Bering someone over her
personal emotional activist cause and V
accurately points out the issue with
white supremacy is that they defund it
as punctuality and like a an hour-based
work schedule so is I need to is that
what you want me to condemn and she's
just interrupting him non-stop it's
fascinating when when is on the CNN Town
Hall debate stage they always have to
interrupt because they're not
journalists yeah they're not here to say
tell me your thoughts on issue they're
here to say here's what you're supposed
to think on issue shut your mouth yeah
just like it reminds me of the Trump CNN
Town Hall thing every time just like
they would ask him stuff and he would
give an answer and then they would just
she would correct him with
incorrect stuff it's just shocking to me
again I bring up you know people that
are that you know lived through that
were alive when when communist countries
were were prevalent when they were like
during the Cold War and it's like why is
it that I know there are people in
Congress that are that are old enough to
remember why are they unaware why is it
that none of the the republicans in
Congress actually will call out the the
anyone on the squad and be like why are
you associating with the DSA when the
DSA is tweeting lenning quotes why are
you associating with them why do you
caucus with them why is that acceptable
and and I mean like the you guys should
I wish that you guys would do it because
this should you should be
absolutely shamed into into a a cave if
you sit there and walk around with your
with with a sickle and Hammer or if
you're you're quoting marks and I mean
not to not the you know go back to the
whole like Rage Against the Machine
thing but the guy's got a pedal that has
a Lenin quote on it like sometimes
history needs a push the push was a
million was 100 million on the it's a
it's a a a foot made by Dunlop it's it's
his W pedal on the side of it I got to
just you could buy that from from Dunlop
yeah Jim dun yeah Dunlop company they
have a it's it's on the side of you can
you can go to the website buy a pedal
that has that quote on it I will bring
up the picture my friend yes you can
absolutely and it says that's wild it
says uh yeah the sometimes history needs
a push and that push like I said that
push is a 100 million dead people so so
let's clarify real quick this is a a
guitar pedal available from Dunlap
Corporation the Dunlap company that you
can go and buy right now with a l quote
on it that says sometimes history needs
a push yes everyone should email that
company asking why they are calling for
the genocide
people I can't think of any more clear
way to put it than that I mean yeah
let's let's let's play the game contact
them and
say so this is like the
signature sometimes history needs a push
yeah it's got a communist star it's got
the red star on it and it's you know on
the side it says uh yeah I just
retweeted it it's on my it's on the top
of my yeah how about how about uh
everybody reach out to Dunlop and ask
them why they're selling genocidal uh
calling for genocide why are they're
supporting genocide and and then see
what they say this kind of stuff the
fact that we accept this as a society is
is because we have a red washed redw
washed educational system that's that's
Dunlop you say huh what do I got here
done with Dunlop this is a Fender guitar
pick there you go I will not use Dunlop
guitar Pi anymore I used to use tortex
those were the ones not anymore that's
Dunlop yeah the the tort the jazz tortex
jazz the purple Jazz 3s no longer well
you talk about my age in the history I I
graduate high school in 9 went off to
college and there's a class on the
Soviet Union and part of the theme of
the class was how that Soviet Union was
there to stay we have to learn to work
with them and they're never going to go
away except that it went away that year
they had to cancel the class because the
Soviet Union fell apart completely
because communism doesn't work socialism
doesn't work even that guy Joe Biden was
head of Foreign Affairs committee at the
time and was one of the leading
proponents of working with the Soviet
Union accepting them as an equal don't
fight them really was he yeah yeah he he
a bunch of lefties where hey we can't
fight these guys I guess they have a
problem with them I don't know but they
were you know they had the view that
that Soviet Union was a workable economy
and it was powerful and it was fine and
we just got to accept them and the
Republicans didn't believe that I mean
some did some didn't but they CR they
got crushed and so they fell apart
because it doesn't work I don't think
they knew about push anything sorry I
don't think they knew about the Googs
yet no who oh back when they said that
probably yeah well well the countries
within there you know Poland they were
fighting for Freedom right they were
they were believing in the right to have
property and things and the stuff they'd
had before they got taken over by the
Communists and and they underestimated
that and frankly threw them under the
bus saying that so Union would never you
know dissolve it dissolved and it diss
you know so people didn't think yeah
people really that was kind of the
general consensus though like it was
information didn't travel the way that
it does now and back then like you
didn't think that the Soviet Union was
going to fall the day before it fell
which it it was on the it was it was
it's on December 26th in case anyone
wants to celebrate it with me every year
I uh should should the Brin wall goes
down yeah you know but it was the end of
the Soviet Union but yeah like let's
let's show this real quick this is uh I
just I just Google searched it there a
website called georg's music I wouldn't
recommend anyone contacting just like a
small distributor like a small retail
store whatever but here's sometimes
history needs a push and that is the C
was it the crybaby W Tom Mell pedal and
uh here you can see from brainy quote
Vladimir lennin sometimes history needs
a push so why don't we ask Dunlop why it
is that I mean that quote is
specifically a call for genocide yeah
historically it's a call for genocide
because the the push is millions dead
the point was that there are people who
are resistant to your your changes and
if you're on the right side of History
you have to push against them and what
was that push they killed a 100 million
people in the history of
Communism so uh no no Dunlop yeah that's
Pro bolik no thanks yeah I I it's
frustrating it's frustrating as hell um
I mean I called out like I was making a
stink about this when uh uh what was his
name Speaker Ryan used a talked about
Rage Against the Machine it was like
2012 okay when when Ryan was speaker I I
I called out uh you know I was like oh
blah blah blah cuz he talked about you
coming out to rage against machine or
something like that and uh coming out to
them what he was walking out like I
thought he was gay I was like no I mean
well Ryan you know speak of Ryan maybe
but either way um he uh he was he caught
some crap from from uh the guys in Rage
and I wrote up a uh an opad they I think
they ran it in AP um but yeah raage on
behalf of the machine no I was like
you're a commi what are you talking
about you know and I was like you you
can't sit there and talk talk about
Republicans being bad when you're a
lital literal communist because there's
it's no comparison any liberal as much
as the the Communists online want to you
know swear up and down that that
capitalism actually kills millions of
people and blah blah blah any liberal
should understand that a liberal Society
is far and a way better than a communist
society and you should be able to
vocally explain why and that's you
should be able to do that you should be
taught that stuff in school yeah and now
we've got you know LGBT he studies in
school and stuff communism couldn't
exist without capitalism exactly in the
first place so all it really is is just
taking everyone back down till it fails
and then everyone has to start over from
scratch it's just Perpetual marks go
marks knew that Marx knew that like the
way marks looked at it was like there's
stages of history and he thought that
Comm that capitalism was going to get so
successful and so abundant that it would
you'd be able to have socialism and and
it would be steps in in uh in history or
whatever thanks for watching watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net